America and China are officially at War
[Music]
that means
for the last few decades China has been
waging a covert economic War through
state-sponsored hacking corporate
Espionage and Market restrictions the
United States is now responding with a
huge set of policies aimed at keeping
China out of the market for
semiconductors telecommunications
equipment Optics and artificial
intelligence it's a complex situation
but the consequences of this will be
absolutely massive our relations between
the two biggest powers in the world
China and the United States on an
Unstoppable collision course we want to
break the historical cycle that a rising
power and a ruling power usually
resolves in Conflict strategic Partners
strategic competitors or strategic
enemies and what does it mean to you to
me and to the rest of the world China is
certainly a rising superpower that wants
to take the United States place in the
world they've said that openly
[Music]
throughout the second half of the 20th
century the United States played a
critical role in helping the Chinese
government build a booming economy
develop Advanced scientific Technologies
and become a global superpower the
common belief among U.S leaders was that
China's rise would lead to cooperation
diplomacy and free trade but China had
another plan in mind the China dream was
less about cooperation and more about
replacing America as the world's
dominant superpower just as America had
replaced the British Empire China was
planning to LeapFrog America all without
firing a single shot the China plan was
simple leveraged low-cost labor to
develop a booming manufacturing sector
all while importing complex technology
to build up future Industries and this
plan was working at least until an
American National Security advisor named
Michael Pillsbury started popularizing
the idea that an economic war with China
was inevitable economics and trade issue
gets mixed together with the chances of
war and are improving taiwan's
deterrence status then it's going to
cause an overall deterioration in our
relations with China's that's going to
affect the market I'm afraid his
writings served as the foundation for
Donald Trump's plan to get tough on
China and they continue to influence the
Biden administration's China policy
today back in 2019 Trump signed an
executive order that blocked Chinese
telecommunication companies like Huawei
from selling equipment in the United
States Huawei was just the first step
and this ban was relatively easy to
implement the company was added to
what's called The Entity list which
catalogs people and companies supporting
or engaging in Terror acts now no one
was saying that Huawei which is best
known for making smartphones was
building bombs or anything like that it
was a little more complicated see the
list includes anyone who helps enhance
the military capabilities of governments
that have repeatedly supported
International terrorism and the U.S
government determined that huawei's
relationship with Iran fit this
description this was just the official
justification though most analysts
didn't believe that Huawei was a current
and present danger to the United States
so I don't think that there's a
widespread consensus across the
technology industry that Huawei
represents a significant enough national
security threat the ban was more about
what could happen in the future Huawei
was grabbing huge market share in
telecommunications equipment before the
ban it was estimated that they would
wind up controlling over 60 percent of
the 5G Market this alone wouldn't have
been that big of a deal but then the U.S
government found back doors in huawei's
Hardware that would allow China to
access worldwide internet traffic Huawei
has deep ties to the Chinese military
and isn't subject to any American
privacy rules when the FBI demanded that
Apple helped them unlock iPhones Apple
refused can the government compel Apple
to write software that we believe would
make hundreds of millions of customers
vulnerable around the world including
the US in China that's not an option if
Huawei was allowed to deploy 5G towers
around the world China would have an
Unstoppable Global surveillance system
so the US government added Huawei to The
Entity list and banned them from selling
5G Hardware to American Allies the ban
also restricted huawei's ability to buy
supplies from factories that use U.S
tools and software this kind of economic
Warfare would only heat up in the years
to come Trump had set the stage for a
confrontation but no one was sure if
Biden would continue the aggressive
stance after all the media narrative
during the 2020 election insisted that
Trump and Biden couldn't be more
different
first of all I guess I'm debating you
not him but that's okay I'm not
surprised the fact is that everything
he's saying so far is simply a lie I'm
not here to call out his lies everybody
knows he's a liar but you I just want
them I I I I want to make sure
watching news coverage made it seem like
they disagreed on every single issue but
here's the weird thing when Biden took
office in 2021 he didn't change course
on China dealing with increased U.S
China competition had become a
bipartisan issue so Biden doubled down
first he passed the chips act which set
aside 52 billion dollars in Grants and
incentives for U.S semiconductor
manufacturing this was a big deal
because it was the first time that the
U.S government had publicly acknowledged
that America was falling behind
America's share of global semiconductor
manufacturing had fallen from 37 in 1990
down to barely 10 percent manufacturing
semiconductor chips is critical to
enabling the development of future
Technologies but America was struggling
for three key reasons first investment
in semiconductor startups had fallen
significantly American Venture
capitalists have been focused on chasing
software companies that didn't need as
much money to scale Instagram raised
less than 60 million dollars before
selling to Facebook for a billion
WhatsApp also needed just 60 million
dollars in funding and they sold for 16
billion dollars semiconductor startups
need a lot more money up front and it's
also a lot riskier that risk led to
America falling behind both in the
number of semiconductor startups getting
funded and the amount of money getting
invested into them alone this wouldn't
be such a problem but it wasn't just
American startups that were struggling
large manufacturers weren't investing in
the United States anymore this was
because while other countries were
subsidizing chip manufacturing the
United States government was actually
penalizing it over regulation had led to
Long lead times to start new projects
with approvals taking years instead of
offering tax incentives to chip
companies most of these new projects
were penalized by the government for
even trying to build this led to factor
number two declining investment in
semiconductor equipment in the United
States lastly even if the investment had
been there to support these projects the
talent just wasn't the United States is
falling behind in stem graduates and for
the past two decades the best jobs for
engineers were all in software why go
work a hard job in a struggling
semiconductor Factory when you could
have a cushy job optimizing ads at one
of the big tech companies America hasn't
been producing enough engineers and the
problem gets even worse two-thirds of
stem PhD students in the United States
are foreigners they want to stay after
graduation but they can't because of
restrictive immigration policies so the
first step in turning the ship around
was just to throw money at the problem
and that's exactly what the chips act
did but reinvigorating a dying industry
is no easy task two of the biggest
semiconductor manufacturers Intel and
tsmc both have access to the same
equipment but only tsmc can make the
best chips profitably at scale
understanding the evolution of these two
companies over the past few decades is
crucial if we want to predict what will
happen between the US and China both
Intel and tsmc are semiconductor
manufacturers but their approaches
couldn't be more different Intel is
integrated meaning they both design and
manufacture chips this is why you'll see
ads and product reviews for Intel
branded CPUs all over the place they
make the chips but they also sell them
directly to Consumers under the Intel
brand you'll never see Linus Tech tips
reviewing a tsmc branded processor
though that's because tsmc is a pure
play Foundry and has pursued a modular
approach they make the chips and iPhones
and video graphics cards and so much
more the consumer never sees the brand
but they still benefit from the tsmc
manufacturing process the trade-off
between modular and integrated has been
a source of both strength and weakness
for these companies Intel's integrated
model delivered extremely high margins
for years their chip design team worked
directly with their manufacturing team
to produce the highest quality products
and for years intel was the best in the
business throughout the 1990s and the
early 2000s CPUs were getting a lot
better each year every new Intel chip
was better than the last so they kept
upgrading their manufacturing plants to
support the latest and greatest products
these chips were top of the line so
Intel could charge a high premium for
them there was a problem though because
the Intel chip design team took orders
from the manufacturing team they
routinely had to design chips that would
work with the equipment that they
already had on hand they were making
great profits but failing to keep up
with The Cutting Edge of manufacturing
tsmc took the opposite approach they
didn't have a chip design team Apple
Nvidia and their other customers were
the ones designing chips and they
demanded the best from tsmc Chip Fabs
are insanely expensive to build but once
you have them up and running the
individual chips are relatively cheap
tsmc was able to capitalize on this they
still have Fabs that are more than 20
years old pumping out chips every day
plenty of companies need cheap chips to
power basic products like toasters and
thermostats and for tsmc this is
basically pure profit Intel never
focused on that kind of contract
manufacturing so all of their older Fabs
were slowly converted to new processes
the March towards better and better
chips required rethinking semi conductor
manufacturing and this is where Intel
really started to fall behind in the
early 2000s there was a big transition
from 200 millimeter Wafers to 300
millimeter Wafers Intel partnered with
Nikon to scale up their process but it
resulted in lower throughput tsmc knew
that they couldn't remain competitive if
they started to slow down so they
partnered with asml to design an
entirely new process for 300 millimeter
this was the start of a long-term
partnership between tsmc and asml and
it's this partnership that is now
driving so much of the conflict between
the US and China these two companies
tsmc and asml they continued to innovate
together developing immersion
lithography to further increase
precision and then finally working on
Extreme ultraviolet lithography or euv
back when they were working on this no
one knew if euv lithography was possible
it honestly sounds insane when you hear
how it works a generator ejects 50 000
tiny droplets of molten tin per second
then a high-powered laser blast
droplet twice the first blast shapes the
tiny tin so the second can vaporize it
into plasma the plasma then emits
extreme ultraviolet radiation that gets
focused into a beam and bounced through
a series of mirrors that beam hits the
Silicon wafer with such Precision that
it can draw transistors into the wafer
with features measuring only five
nanometers and then it does this
billions or trillions of times to create
a computer chip it's truly the most
advanced technology Humanity has ever
developed these machines cost 120
million dollars each and they have more
than a hundred thousand Parts asml is
responsible for making these machines
and they're based in the Netherlands but
they can't do it alone there are more
than 800 suppliers involved in making a
single euv machine and this supply chain
is overwhelmingly controlled by the
United States and its allies China has
been trying to catch up though they're
quickly developing the technology to
manufacture faster and faster chips but
they still rely heavily on equipment
from International suppliers like asml
at Best China several years behind but
they are incredibly motivated to solve
this problem the US couldn't just wait
around for China to copy this Cutting
Edge technology though that's why the
Biden Administration started restricting
sales of high-end processors to China
back in September the ban was targeted
specifically at nvidia's top-of-the-line
Graphics processing units these gpus are
way more powerful than the gaming cards
that are typically found in your average
desktop computer the a100 and upcoming
h100 series of Nvidia gpus are critical
for training cutting-edge AI models not
only are they faster than consumer cards
but they have a lot more memory and
bandwidth when AI researchers want to
train a new model they need tons of
these high-end chips working together in
a cluster to get the best results
preventing China from buying these
Nvidia chips basically meant preventing
China from building powerful AI it was a
massive hit to the Chinese tech industry
but it wasn't exactly a death blow that
would come later the response to the
Nvidia band was Swift
torrent of Chinese aircraft missiles and
ships moved towards Taiwan beijing's
provocative actions are a significant
escalation in its long-standing attempt
to change the status quo but when you
look at the history of U.S China
relations over the past decade it starts
to look absolutely insane China has
banned nearly every American tech
company from operating in the country
YouTube and Facebook are banned in China
but Tick Tock is allowed to operate in
the United States we're looking at Tick
Tock we may be banning Tick Tock clearly
things are out of balance tension
between the United States and China has
been rising for years now but October
7th 2022 will likely be a date
remembered for decades U.S President
Biden extended a trump-era National
Emergency rule Banning U.S firms from
investing in Chinese military-linked
companies basically China would no
longer be able to buy certain
semiconductor chips made anywhere in the
world with U.S equipment now Not only
was China banned from purchasing
critical chips but they couldn't even
buy the Machinery to make those chips by
themselves it got more complicated
though because of these new restrictions
Americans who are working in China were
forced to choose between quitting their
jobs and losing American
tons of Executives and Engineers left
their jobs to comply with the new rules
leaving Chinese semiconductor
manufacturers massively understaffed
these were the broadest set of export
controls issued in a decade and while
they were similar to the Trump Crackdown
on Huawei these new rules were far wider
in scope restricting access to high
performance Computing was a declaration
of economic war on the future of China
the United States was now openly
attempting to undermine China's future
military capacity and technological
development the impact of these
restrictions will dramatically reorder
China's priorities over the past few
decades China has transformed its
economy by becoming the world's
manufacturer we've all seen made in
China labels on everything from
McDonald's Happy Meal toys to brand new
iPhones but even though it feels like
China manufactures just about everything
they are missing a few key pieces of the
puzzle China has specialized in
labor-intensive manufacturing the
country has over a billion people and
the vast majority of Chinese workers
were living impoverished lives until
just recently the this gave China a huge
advantage in simple manufacturing
clothes toys and many other products
were way cheaper to make using Chinese
labor so companies across the globe
started Outsourcing the Chinese economy
boomed and even after wages started to
rise the Chinese manufacturing ecosystem
was so robust that it still had major
advantages over other countries any
entrepreneur could visit China and leave
with reliable manufacturing partnership
in just a few weeks but even though
China had become dominant in this
labor-intensive manufacturing they had
failed to invest in capital intensive
manufacturing products like
semiconductors were still made in the
United States Europe Japan and Taiwan
even though the iPhone was assembled in
China the chip that powered it was not
the Huawei ban shined a light on this
issue if China could no longer import
chips to power their new 5G Towers they
would need to make them domestically all
of a sudden tiny Chinese companies that
made inferior chips were the only option
for a company like Huawei so money
started flooding into the high-tech
manufacturing sector China is still
behind in semiconductor manufacturing
but for the last few decades this wasn't
a problem because they could just buy
and import them from other countries not
anymore they need to start making them
locally and fast the path to
cutting-edge chip Manufacturing in China
will be a Rocky one they don't just need
to build their own tsmc they also have
to build their own asml and all of asml
suppliers the mirrors the lasers every
single one of those thousands of parts
will need to be built independently of
the traditional supply chain it feel
feels like an impossible task but China
doesn't really have any other option
they simply can't afford to fall behind
technologically the big question now is
how long will it take them to catch up
even though it will be a Monumental task
China does have some Tailwinds that
should speed things up first off they
don't really need to develop anything
entirely new here they already know that
extreme ultraviolet lithography Works
they've seen asml machines in action and
they just need to replicate what the
rest of the world has already done
Chinese chip companies are already
working on this problem and they are
producing some results the yields are
low and these aren't profitable
manufacturing operations but that
doesn't really matter in this case the
government needs this to happen and will
invest any amount of money to get
results and if they pull it off and
develop their own tsmc equivalent well
then we'll have a new set of problems in
the past China's dependence on foreign
technology companies has been seen as a
key bargaining chip why would China
invade Taiwan when they need to keep
tsmc's manufacturing facilities online
chip manufacturing is extremely precise
one of these factories isn't going to
withstand a rocket hitting it so if you
want to keep them producing chips you
can't invade Taiwan well now the cost of
a Taiwan Invasion has just decreased
China can't access tsmc chips anyway so
it's a lot less risky to go to war but a
lot of analysts believe that China's
military response won't Target Taiwan at
all instead China might look to the
ukraine-russia conflict as a way to flex
their independence when these chip bans
were first floated earlier this year one
possible scenario was that America could
use the potential trade restrictions as
leverage to keep China from entering the
Ukraine conflict the Russian military
has had their own semiconductor problems
the Russian military is taking chips
from dishwashers and refrigerators to
fix their military hardware because
there are no semiconductors anymore even
though China isn't able to manufacture
Cutting Edge chips they could still help
Supply Russia with plenty of resources
for for their war machine now that these
bands are in place the United States has
one less card to play in diplomatic
relations with China let's hope it
doesn't escalate further there are other
steps China can take in response to the
chip bans though first there are always
loopholes the Biden Administration is
likely to clarify exactly what is and is
not restricted in the coming months
right now the rules are extremely broad
but the United States has a narrower
goal here essentially this is entirely
about artificial intelligence the Biden
Administration is very worried about the
transformative potential of AI and
believes that there are serious National
Security implications that's why the
bands are designed around certain fixed
performance metrics right now only a
small fraction of chips fit these
Cutting Edge definitions but over time
more and more chips will be restricted
the United States is basically saying AI
technology is the future and China can't
come with us the bands are designed to
only restrict AI related products so
China should be able to find loopholes
to keep other kinds of manufacturing
online after all American companies
still enjoy cheaper Chinese
manufacturing and as more and more
products become smart and internet
connected they will need a ready supply
of chips the chip that powers your smart
toaster is much less sophisticated than
a top of the line Nvidia GPU though
those basic chips will still trade
freely between the United States and
China but the economic War over
artificial intelligence will rage on but
here's where it gets really complicated
it's pretty clear that the United States
is purely focused on high-end AI chips
they see it as a key strategic advantage
and have put these restrictions in place
to help the U.S retain dominance there
the risk is that China won't see it this
way they could interpret these bans as
an all-out economic war and feel forced
to retaliate so if they do retaliate
what would that look like well if
America is punishing Chinese tech
companies what if China punishes
American tech companies the biggest
American tech company with operations in
China is Apple but restricting Apple
might hurt China more than the United
States there are millions of Chinese
citizens working for Apple either
directly at Foxconn or in various parts
of the Apple supply chain restricting
Apple could force iPhone production to
move to another country airpods are
already starting to be assembled in
Vietnam and it would be impossible for
Foxconn to find another company like
apple to work with China has a trade
imbalance with the United States exports
to the United States are much more
important to the Chinese economy than
vice versa this is a big part of the
reason why the Trump tariffs hurt China
more than America and why Biden kept
them in place they were an effective
economic tool so China is in a tough
spot they clearly don't want to lose out
on the next major technological era
artificial intelligence is of keen
interest to Global superpowers Vladimir
Putin once said that the nation that
leads in AI will be the ruler of the
world China recognizes the key role that
AI will play in the coming years so
they're clearly going to do something
but the real question is why haven't we
heard from them yet well the timing of
these chip bands couldn't be worse from
a Chinese perspective they landed just
as the Chinese Communist party was
conducting the 20th National Congress
where party delegates meet to select a
leader cesium Peng was further
consolidating power and dealing with the
United States would have to wait he
cemented a third term and packed the
leadership with devout loyalists his
message was one of military strength and
technological superiority and no dissent
would be permitted every rival had been
successfully dispatched and no clear
successor was named previously the
Chinese Communist Party had followed an
informal retirement guideline whereby
officials over the age of 68 would step
aside despite now being 69 years old C
is determined to stay in control during
the Congress there was even a dramatic
moment when his predecessor hujin Tao
was abruptly escorted out no one knows
if he supports C remaining in power
indefinitely so now the stage is
properly set for economic war between
China and the United States
has made it clear that he will not back
down to any foreign superpower so we
just have to wait these two giant
economies have become so intertwined
that perhaps disputes were inevitable we
can only hope that the conflict remains
confined to the economic realm one of
the last questions remaining is what
will happen to taiwan's semiconductor
industry and to understand that you have
to watch my video on the history of tsmc
next thanks for watching